- [Voiceover] Which of
the following represents
all solutions X comma Y to the system
of equations shown below?
This is an interesting
system of equations,
because this is a linear
equation, this first one,
but the second one is nonlinear.
You have a Y squared right over here.
Well this one actually can
be solved with a substitution
because two Y plus six
needs to be equal to X,
but then we also know that X is equal
to Y squared minus nine.
So we could take Y squared minus nine
and substitute it for X.
So if you do that, you
then can solve for Y,
the Y of a solution to this system.
So if two Y plus six is equal to
Y squared minus nine.
And so, let's see.
Let's just get zeros on
the left-hand side, so
we could subtract two Y from both sides.
I'll write that.
Subtract two Y there.
We could subtract six from both sides.
And then on the left-hand side
we're going to be left with zero.
And on the right-hand side,
you're gonna have Y
squared minus 15 minus,
actually, let me write
it the other way around.
Y squared, I'm gonna write the minus two Y
minus 15.
And now to solve for the
Ys that would satisfy
this quadratic right over here,
we could factor this quadratic,
we could factor this quadratic expression.
And let's see, the way I
would do that is first,
can I think of two numbers
whose product is negative 15?
And immediately the
numbers three and five,
either negative three, positive five,
or positive three, negative five jump out,
and whose sum is negative two.
Well if the sum is negative that means
that the negative number has to have
a larger magnitude.
So it's going to be
negative five and three.
Negative five and three's
product is negative 15,
their sum is negative two.
And if what I'm doing right
now looks a little bit
like voodoo to you, I
encourage you to review
factoring quadratic
expressions on Khan Academy.
Do a search on Khan Academy
for factoring quadratic expressions.
But we now know how to factor.
This is going to be zero is equal to,
and we can write this as
Y minus five times Y plus three.
Well, if you have the
product of two things
that are equal to zero,
that means that you could
get this to be equal zero
by making one or both
of these equal to zero.
So the solutions are gonna be,
how do you make this one equal zero?
Well Y would be equal to five.
And how do you make
this one equal to zero?
Well Y would be equal to negative three.
Either one of these
would make one of these,
Y equals five would make this zero,
which would make the
entire expression zero,
so this is a solution.
And Y equals negative
three would make this zero,
which makes this entire expression zero,
so it is also a solution.
Now we could go back and
try to solve for the Xs,
or we could immediately
look at our choices
and say well do any of these
choices have Y equal five
and Y equals negative three
as at least the Y coordinates
of solutions?
And these first two don't
even have two choices,
but this one right over here,
they're actually trying
to trick us a little bit.
Because we have this number,
five and negative three,
and it's like hey, maybe this one,
but this isn't Y equals five.
This is X equals five.
And when X equals five, Y
is equal to negative three.
That's X and that's Y.
The first coordinate is X,
the second coordinate is Y.
So Y equals five and Y
equals negative three.
This one is Y is equal to five
and Y is equal to negative three.
So you should feel immediately pretty good
about this choice right over here.
This one puts the five
and the negative three
in for the X coordinate.
That says X is equal to five
and X is equal to negative three.
So, you wouldn't, if I
was under time pressure,
I would just stop there
and I would move on
to the next question, because I feel good
about this choice.
But if you want to go
back and feel good that
when Y equals five, X equals 16
and when Y equals negative
three, X is equal to zero,
you can go back and substitute
into this first equation.
Because we have two times five
plus six is equal to X.
So when Y is equal to
five, you have 10 plus six,
you have X is equal to 16
when Y is equal to five.
And that's what we saw right over here,
when Y is five, X is 16.
And when Y is negative three,
two times negative three
plus six is equal to X.
This on the left-hand side is going to be
negative six plus six,
X is equal to zero.
So when Y is negative
three, X is equal to zero.
So, we took a little
extra time to make sure
that we feel good about
this, but once again
under time pressure, I
wouldn't have necessarily gone
through to this extra length.